hey kids it's me kevin smith almost 30
years ago i made my first movie clerks
but i've grown as a filmmaker since then
man that's why i just finished clark's
three ladies and gentlemen that's right
clerks three is done and i'm taking it
right to your hometown man join me for
clerks 3 colon the convenience tour come
watch clerks 3 with me and then
afterwards we'll q a about it man the
tour starts september 4th at the cal
basin theater in red bank new jersey
right by jane salem bob's secret stash
goes up one coast down the other clerks
three the convenience tour man you are
supposed to be there today with me
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to a bonus
episode of unbearable my name is chuck
staton i'm brad rohr i'm ray harrington
uh we're gonna try to be putting up
bonus episodes here and there from our
past we both
all three of us have a lot of podcasting
in our past a lot of video projects and
one of the very fun things we do is brad
and i have moderated at a lot of comic
cons over the years that's true so one
of the things we got to do at rhode
island comic con 2021 was moderate a
clerk's panel and now that clerks 3 is
being released uh we thought that it
would be really fun to repost that
clerk's panel i'm living on borrowed
time i'm gonna make a movie
everything in the script is something
someone i know said i'm not even
supposed to be here today
take off your pants
that's how we did it in the 90s son
clerks 3 in movie theaters two nights
only september 13th and 15th so that day
uh we had a big big big cast on this
stage brad can you tell me exactly who
was there we had brian o'halloran we had
jeff anderson
marilyn gigliotti
scott schiaffo
trevor fairman
kevin wiseman great representatives from
clerks and clerks too that's correct and
uh yeah we had a great time that was a
very crazy weekend kevin was 45 minutes
late to his panel so the rhode island
comic-con organizers asked us to go up
and riff on stage for the audience for
that long
but i'll say this cool little shout out
uh i went to a poker tournament recently
at smod castle right in leonardo new
jersey which is in the same building as
the quick stop and there was a guy there
and he said hey man did i see you at
rhode island comic con i was like oh
yeah we moderate the clerk's panel he
goes didn't you fill in for kevin with
your buddy brad and i was like yeah i
did he goes you guys were hilarious i
don't know if that stuff was written
ahead of time but it was so funny and i
was like wow i'm like are you from rhode
island he goes i'm from austin texas i
only came up for the clerk's reunion
panel and i was like wow that's crazy
yeah that guy vanished into the ether
i think you're gonna say that guy
van helsing
why would you think that
and that guy
well folks it was me
well folks folks that's a story for
another day
how i became that man is a story for
nothing i am so confused
you should be lasso
this originally aired as an episode of
the chuck and brad podcast but we're
rearing here as a bonus uh hopefully
there's a lot of stuff like this but
please enjoy uh the clerks reunion panel
hosted by brad and myself from rhode
island comic con 2021.
how many people by applause were at
kevin smith's panel last night
was that amazing or what oh my god
uh anyone come to use this panel just
all right yeah all right wow you are the
die hard uh clerks fans and guess who we
have back there we got everybody else so
i'm gonna bring up your moderators
ladies and gentlemen if you were at
kevin's uh panel you saw these guys up
here for about a half an hour beforehand
let's hear it from my friends from the
chuck and brad podcast chuck and brad
thank you rhode island comic-con we are
very excited to be here with all y'all
for this clerk's panel
are you excited
who was here last night for kevin's
panel
okay so that many people already don't
like us sorry about that yes that many
people had to sit through 40 minutes of
our nonsense last night uh we are
excited we're gonna get right to the to
the clerks here uh we're gonna ask some
questions to prime the pump and then
we'll turn it over to uh you so
start your brain boxes working and uh
get those questions ready so
that was a prime the pump is a gross
metaphor no it's not all right keep
going
without
what a great segue let's bring out uh
our folks from clerks our friends from
corks please put your rhode island paws
together
for the clerks we have brian o'halloran
we have jeff anderson
[Applause]
perfect
marilyn gigliotti
[Applause]
and finally kevin wiseman keep on
clapping
i have questions written down welcome
everybody how you guys doing
doing good thanks for having us very
good
by the way this is uh trevor furman's
first convention ever
[Applause]
so
y'all are totally is a gross [ __ ] 90s
thing to say but you all are popping his
cherry
i thought i popped his cherry
well that that was in your trailer and
that's for the behind the scenes dvd
are you guys having a good experience at
rhode island comic con
this is my first time here in rhode
island and i'm excited to be here meet
you all
yeah
i mean
as you know i've done this show like six
years and uh i've been pitching this
[ __ ] get-together for like all those
times and finally steve and the group
finally go okay
and finally decide to bring us in uh
like this and plus this was the year
just before kovid that jeff said all
right i'll come down off my mountain and
uh
mingle amongst you mortals uh and he's
here but uh what a way to do it um not
only bringing us in but bringing kevin
in and having the movies pop up and the
movie schwag downstairs it's uh it's
full-on you know
pre-publicity for the clerk's three
hopefully in june next year comes out
and uh
yeah give it up
wow
you guys here in the rhode island
providence and also the surrounding new
england boston and even guys coming up
from maryland stuff like you guys have
been supportive of the films all these
years so it deserves that this would be
the show that we get everybody together
for hell yeah hell yeah thank you very
much man and uh
since kevin's not here today
we've collectively decided we're going
to tell you about clerks 3.
[Laughter]
here it is
jay and silent bob get married
it's a scoop
you've been saying elias is the minister
now that's a subtitle i like that
um all right let's uh let's kick off
some questions here uh clerks one folks
when you auditioned
for this little indie movie in in you
know let's call it 1993 was there even
one brain cell that was like you know
what 28 years from now i'm going to be
at rhode island comic-con
and so many people are going to be here
to see me
scott
wow the uh comic-con culture or the
the whole phenomenon of what comic-con
has become over the last 20 years
really wasn't happening back now at all
in the 80s late 80s early 90s i had
attended some with
friends of mine who were vendors and it
was comics yeah and comic books mostly
and comic book artists and uh so no i i
had no clue of any of that i just was uh
hoping to
get myself uh
noticed as a character actor and back
then uh
no cell phone no
internet so
actors would follow the trade papers to
find audition notices and kevin put an
audition notice in my local paper
luckily because i was an hour and a half
away
i wasn't anywhere near those guys down
the shore i'm way up north in new jersey
so i'm just happy i saw the audition
notice and
got down did my monologue and they
called me back very thankfully and
but no could never have seen any any of
this coming at all i mean i'm holding
julie's gum
i'm holding
you are such a plan you're such a
panderer hold on i got gum too
i was afraid i was gonna put somebody's
eye out
um for me
you know
i used it as another platform because i
had been doing community theater with
brian
and uh i would not have thought that
it's like you know it would be so well
received or anything like that i didn't
even know about comic conventions um and
i moved out to california
in 97
and it wasn't probably until like early
2000's i'm not even quite sure that
somebody contacted me
about doing conventions and since i
hadn't heard about it i thought i was
like somebody's trying to scam me right
um
and uh he was telling me he's like yeah
people will pay for your autographs i'm
like get out
um
and
he listed a few celebrities and i'm like
great i actually happen to know a few of
those jason and jeremy london so i
immediately contacted them
and they told me oh yeah it's like this
is this is a whole thing and this is
like a beginning of emails and computers
and stuff um
so once he told me about that i was like
okay
um
and uh yeah it was pretty pretty cool
actually um and i i say to a lot of you
that that come up and i'm like had i
known
about
conventions like this
i would have been attending you know
before because this is my thing this is
my jam i like it um i'm not
the uber uber
like fan in that sense that knows all
the
terms and all that kind of stuff but i
mean definitely
something that i i would definitely have
gone to nice guys
it's us
what's an audition
perfect
no uh
i actually went to the
the auditions with a friend of mine who
was supposed to play dante
and he was terrible and i wound up
making fun of them i was like dude
you're the worst actor i've ever seen
and he was like well don't why don't you
audition so i said to kevin i was like
my friend wants me to audition who
should i be and he said you know i wrote
this part for jay jay muse but i'm not
sure he's going to be able to do it so
you'll be my backup j
i was like all right
and so i auditioned as jay
that'd be a whole new movie
noinge
i was like kevin what is this
mooch you're like no nooch
so i need you to say i'll suck this
[ __ ] i'll suck this [ __ ] i'll suck
anything that
moves that was actually the audition i
know i know
and anybody
anybody who has the clerk's 10 dvd the
auditions are on the extra dvd outtakes
and stuff so if you want to see what not
to do in auditions
uh it's a great teachable moment that
that thing uh yeah when i auditioned uh
first of all i auditioned uh on the
second day because i forgot about the
auditions entirely um but thankfully the
owner of the first avenue playhouse in
first avenue in uh atlantic islands
called me the following monday morning
going where were you i thought you were
going to come to this audition like holy
[ __ ] was that last night
and i auditioned and i went in there
they said i said how many principals are
there's like they're six but their casts
were just auditioning day players i was
like okay and i went in there with this
monologue
from a play called wait until dark and
it's a very evil monologue it's a play
that me and marilyn did together and i
made a dialogue mixed together into a
monologue and did it and he was like oh
[ __ ] man
i wish i had a villain you'd be perfect
in this movie as the villain but uh all
right called me back a couple of days
later i came back for a reading just
with kevin to read a call back to read
the
independent contractor scene and then i
loved what was there and he's like what
do you think i'm like it's hilarious
like the other guy is really funny but
you know the dialogue together is funny
he's like do you want to do it i was
like sure now i didn't know what the
film was about didn't know who these
guys were i thought i was a day player
of these two convenience store clerks in
this movie that the main movie comes in
and then the two main characters leave
overhearing this [ __ ] conversation
about star wars and i thought that was
it he goes no no the movie is called
clerks and you would be one of the main
clerks i was like
i was told by the guy videotaping the
auditions that the principals were all
cast he was like yeah yeah don't worry
about that i'll take care of that i was
like oh okay
and there you have it so when you say
like did you ever think back then
auditioning we'd be here talking at a
comic-con uh like
scott said comic-cons were all about
comics back then right right not not
media guests um who busted down the door
and like [ __ ] y'all we're stealing all
your comic book money now um
but here i am stealing all your comic
book money and drinking a [ __ ] i
assure you we're open beer so right
that's amazing
the highlight of that comment is i'm
drinking a beer so here we go
perfect
well i have a question that i think uh
you guys might have varied answers on
do you feel like when you meet people
who are fans of clerks
that they expect you to be just like
your characters
does that happen kevin let's start with
kevin on that yeah
do you get a lot of people going up
there defending your love of lord of the
rings
it's it's crazy to me that um
you know i was in the second clerks i'm
not sure if you remember but um
you know i worked one day on that on
that film and there are things you do in
your career where you
could have potentially worked for
a year on something and you think this
is gonna be them getting the gold for
the awards are gonna
nobody sees it and um
some things you do
obviously i knew kevin and i had seen
the first one which was great
but there are some things you do that
really land with the audience and with
the public and this is certainly
one of those but there's always a
certain clerk's fan is a certain type of
person
and i mean that with love there's a
there's
there's a certain energy easy
all right no no i mean i'll know when
someone's approaching me i can kind of
gauge okay this is there's gonna be some
sort of lord of the rings question
coming i feel it
and uh i'm generally generally right um
and even today out here meeting everyone
everyone's been great like you guys know
the dialogue better than i do and i'm
having a hard time even remembering that
day
i do remember pretty drunk we were
pretty drunk yeah
no but i do remember i do remember a
mixture of
oatmeal and pea soup
for
that was my barf yeah and uh
but but yes uh it it's it's crazy to me
the the the detail
uh
that the
fans can can conjure at a moment's
notice so it's really nice meeting
everyone and it's been great meeting
everyone today and if i haven't met you
please say hello
excellent
trevor
what about you i know this is your first
con but in your real world life yeah
what has your been experienced about
people approaching about your experience
on clerks too well people assume that
i'm a lot like that character but in
their defense i i am a lot like that
character all right
still a virgin
uh
love jesus and the transformers
[ __ ] a donkey once
[Laughter]
twice i should have gotten honestly i
should have gotten co-writing credits
because i think kevin sort of cripped
from my life heavily
well i remember when you were developing
elias's delivery and we were like a
couple of days of doing read-through
readings and rehearsals with kevin
before shooting clerks two and
you were you were struggling or you were
coming with these different angles of
how to to to say this kind of dialogue
which anybody who's work reads kevin's
dialogue especially it's very verbose
it's a lot of nomenclature that you go
like what where is he going with this
but you working through your process and
us watching it was really interesting
because there'd be some rehearsals where
you'd leave you'd go back home and kevin
and jeff and scott
we'd all look at each other like
dude do we know where he's going and we
were like i don't know where he's going
but i'm kind of liking him finding this
character it's it's weird because his
speech canter and everything else is
just so funny because you're used to
people in kevin's world being like
but he was just like uh listen um you
know and it was really cool seeing that
process and it was great seeing
especially in clerks three how you you
you bring this to a nice head to it
yeah he i think he started off a lot
more
um
hostile and then gradually
we just sort of
honed it more
he was a lot more likable when he was
more like an abused dog
and so that we just kind of got closer
to that and i think that made it funnier
but i don't know
yeah it was an interesting process i
remember that too
i just remember you being you were very
vulnerable you seem very vulnerable
which maybe you're suggesting you don't
that's not really a milieu in the in the
clerk's world so that's probably
it's kind of the audience's way in
through a character like that when
there's vulnerability god help you
elias is the proxy for i think so
well i mean the vulnerability i also
remember did you experience this a lot
kevin would yell
lines to me
just say this say this say this
is that something that you guys
experienced throughout the whole process
were just on the fly try this try this
try this uh the first one no
uh it was strict to the he was
incredibly strict with the script to
almost to a point where
hang on to your hats fellow actors up
here where line readings were given to
even to the vocal texture where you're
like you know it's like [ __ ] nails on
a chalkboard to an actor i'm like i'm
not a parrot but okay
um now
he's more of that do this say it like
this say it like that or not say it like
but have dante say this we did a good
bit of that
in three
after we got what was scripted
kevin would come in from outside after
having um
herbal medicine
treatments for his
back yeah let's say that um
and he would be like
why don't we try this
and then this and then this and we would
do like 20 different kind of ending
lines of things and
it does work and then you think when
you're done with that day oh we did some
great stuff and then you see the edit
like
we still went with what he scripted that
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
nice how about everybody else do you
guys feel like the expectations are the
thing that i get asked probably the
most frequently is did i
was i do
did i really dislike smoking or have it
disdain for smoking in real life
and it's crazy because anybody who knows
anything about my life which is pretty
public on social media i battled very
serious addictions for many years
alcohol and drugs but i didn't smoke
cigarettes of all things
i did grow up hating it my mom smoked
and i tried to get her to stop forever
and ever and then like a huge hypocrite
i just became addicted to everything
else in my own adult life but um that
was not a stretch to
loathe cigarettes it was pretty bizarre
that i ended up getting to play that
character
um there are some aspects of veronica
that are like me
and no
it's not that
38.
sorry
but i i become very loyal to whoever is
my partner um and
i will go out of my way to do special
things um so that that's
you know that's
let's hear more about those special
things
i said no it's not that
we're changing the stranger things panel
to special things battle
it's funny because when people say about
the the dante character and stuff and
like you know he's a bit of a whiny
[ __ ] and stuff like that
and stuff i'm like it's so funny because
you know i'm technically the straight
guy uh so to speak when it comes to the
comedy of these movies and you know
where the i'm in the normal world what
everybody else is in their extreme
worlds but in real life i'm kind of more
of a randall personality
and anybody there's quite a few people
in this audience who i've worked with
and hung out with they kind of like oh
yeah
you're definitely a randall while jeff
is more of the quiet
kind of like reserve more of an elias
you too
yeah
i was wondering why you kept talking
about pillow pants it's so weird
that's great
if people want to start lining up for
questions we're happy to take audience
questions you can just line up at either
microphone there you go i like that oh
[ __ ] the guy in the camouflage here
comes the hit
all right
give us uh give us your name my name's
jacob hey jacob
and in honor of it being comic-con
i was wondering if
whoever wants to answer it
if you could be any superhero what would
it be
any superhero let's start on the end
kevin
[Music]
uh i'm gonna go with the flash
ooh good choice
i think i'll go with professor x
okay nice
batman
excellent delivery probably wonder woman
since you know i'm so short she's the
amazon
yeah i'd probably be underdog
it's a good choice that was good always
saving poly purebred how the [ __ ] am i
supposed to follow up underdog
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you know what black black panther
why not why not me
yeah yeah let's let's see the internet
blow that [ __ ] up now
once again the white guy trying to steal
a role made for people of color that
[ __ ] privileged bastard
thank you jacob good question we'll go
over here what's your name i'm parker hi
parker my question for the panel is what
is the best prank you've played on each
other wow
pricks some pranks are you guys
ribbon
you got some pranks up your sleeves jeff
how's the prank of all pranks um we were
shooting clerks too
and we were shooting a scene up on the
roof
and they had a ladder to get up there i
was it was uh dante and randall
rebuilding rebuilding the burnt down
store after we bought it and they had a
saw up there a table saw and uh a
handsaw
and i said bry watch this and i went up
there and i hit the saw for about two
minutes and i was like ah
and brian goes holy [ __ ] he cut his
finger off
and so i leaned over the roof i'm like
get a medic get a medic now we had told
all the crew the medic themselves like
this is the prank we're gonna pull later
on when we're doing the scene the medic
grabs his bag kevin's in the store with
the monitor go ahead well kevin ran in
the store
at this point i'd come down off the
ladder and kevin ran in the store and he
got paper towels
and he came running back out but the
beautiful thing was through the whole
thing and he was scared scared but he
still had like a cigarette dangling out
of his mouth
you weren't too worried about me you're
still smoking
so on on the set that was our biggest
prank i mean otherwise we didn't really
prank prank jay is more of a goof on on
set more than a prankster i once
convinced jeffy popped my
cherry that's a good prank that was a
prank
who was that at prank on
the audience
that's a great question thank you parker
and great answer over here what do we
got what's your name hey my name is meg
hi meg uh we saw you guys like a month
ago up in maine and one thing you you
were saying is that you're not an actor
jeff
right so what are you
jeff well doctor
what are you
i was born in a small town
[Laughter]
yeah no no i'm not an actor this is why
we do the movies once every 14 years it
takes me that long to convince me like a
[ __ ] cicada
yeah no uh i mean i don't know what i
could say i'm not an actor yeah but you
are a writer you are a director you've
directed some major people in a great
film of your own i directed trevor
that's how we found trevor that's right
that's how we found trevor um
yeah no i i live in the woods
[Music]
which always sounds strange
i i'm kind of out of la and
i just chill out man
he's a woodsman but he also is and he
doesn't say this a lot but he also is an
accomplished artist he makes mosaics
incredible
framed mosaics he's had everybody's
picturing me in a room with like 80 year
old women
i'm like rose will you pass me that
thank you rose well you've had an
exhibit in now in las vegas and stuff so
it's something he takes his time with
especially he doesn't announce he's not
a self-promoter at that at all but i've
seen his work and it's stunning and it's
good stuff so he has this kind of
quiet life that you know years from now
you were like oh my god he [ __ ] built
the [ __ ] mosaic inside of so-and-so
kind of thing so um
but
uh this is today
by june you're going to see the
phenomenal actor jeff anderson playing
randall in clerks 3.
and he won't be able he won't be able to
avoid that title after june
jeff did you feel you'll never see me
after clerks three yeah be back in the
[ __ ] woods
hey jeff did was it jeff did it feel uh
over here over here did it feel
did it feel what god
yes
jeff you were wonderful in the film
uh did you feel
comfortable being back on set or did it
take a minute to adjust or did you feel
like you know riding a horse sort of
thing after all i mean there's something
strange about the store like as soon as
we went back to the store that that
store is like frozen in time and it's
like stepping back into it um i said
this to brian i said you know i probably
wouldn't have done
two or three uh if it wasn't for brian
uh it's like getting together with brian
uh as soon as we read and we hang out it
just becomes those two guys so uh
without brian you know like like i said
going to the store is one thing and
going there with brian it just felt like
old times that's awesome you're making
me cry
thank you for the question thank you
back over here what do we got what's
your name hi my name is robert hi robert
hey robert hi uh my question is uh in
any of the viewer sku movies did you
have like a scene or a line that you
really liked that ended up getting cut
great question
yeah um
there was one scene
it was more like uh it was it happened
it was in uh i forget what movie was but
at the end i was like [ __ ] you kevin no
i'm just kidding
um no there's nothing that i was just
like oh my god i wish we kept it i mean
we've seen a cut of clerks three
recently
and there have been two scenes that have
been cut where i was like ah
i really liked those scenes those were
cool i guess were they yeah they were
that first scene that got caught and
then maybe remember later in the movie
that other scene got cut
both were mine yeah um but yeah so i i
told kevin i said yeah that's going to
be on the deleted dvd scene thing right
and he's like well i would assume so i'm
like oh okay so there are those type of
things but nothing i was just like oh
you [ __ ] ruined the movie to the one
scene i totally agree with cutting was
in the original clerks when dante gets
shot
[Laughter]
otherwise i don't sit here i always told
kevin randle should have shot him
[Laughter]
i'm kind of why
i'm kind of heartbroken over a cat from
clerk's three you guys know what it is
but i i don't know if i should say it
because it's a it's not really a spoiler
but i probably shouldn't say it
say it
there's not cover
i'm kind of you have a million dollars
to blow on that [ __ ] non-disclosure
agreement i'm kind of i'm heartbroken
over sergio
sergio yeah yeah just say surgery
there's a cut of the scene that uh if
you remember from a reboot they called
dante sergio remember that scene
all right obviously big reboot [ __ ]
fans
anyway there's a there's a call back to
that reboot kind of thing that's it
though everything else that i i agree
with you
nice
who was next there we go
hey guys cj good to see you cj hey i'm
cj um
so mr
on a recent uh podcast you came out
saying on clerks3 you took something
from the set a pickle and a pouch
um
so that was you
[Music]
[Laughter]
it was i i was one the pickle in a pouch
thief it wasn't a pickle are you the
lawyer representing quick stop for the
yes lawsuit for stealing a two dollar
pickle and the pickle in the pouch
that's why i've been stalking you for
last night
finally that is funny actually on
clerk's three
if you ate something in the store you
had to write it down
i had like 10 packs of gum i had to pay
for it at the end of it
did did any of y'all have anything on
from clerks 3 that you were able to take
or hold on to that you really liked do i
really want to have to testify at my
trial later on
uh yeah we we uh we're
one of our one of the greatest crew
members and we actually have a quite a
few of the crew members who came up on a
trip specifically
[Applause]
we got uh
some of our hair and makeup people up
here who did phenomenal work to make
this [ __ ] plus of a [ __ ] face
uh pleasant to people to look at so i uh
they should definitely get a nomination
for special effects when it comes out
um they are here but one of the great
guys there was a literally this is his
name i'm not lying to you being i'm
pandering you because we're at a comic
con our prop master was named thor that
is his name
and thor at the end he's like hey man do
you want anything you know any props
from the set that you would have loved
and uh and so i named radloff a few
things like yo you can't have that but
we could do this and we can do that blah
blah and i was like all right so i have
a few things uh that i have in my
collection now i've have things from
every movie uh this jersey uh is
actually from they did two for each of
us there's a hockey scene on the roof
again and this is the quick stop jerseys
that will be coming out later next year
for sale for for every all right uh but
you know as me and jeff and a few of us
are executive producers on the film i'm
like i want a jersey and they were like
well you can't have the one you wore in
that scene but we can do this i'm like
all right done and done so uh those are
the type of things i loved grabbing off
the set
because i used my jacket in the original
which i use again in this one nice
um
but i did have another piece of wardrobe
and i did ask which is i hope it's on
hold
um because another jacket that i use i'm
like it's not maybe as iconic as the
original but i really liked it uh so i
did ask to hopefully maybe be be able to
buy it down the road so that's what i'm
hoping but i really didn't have very
much
props
to ha to get kind of get back because i
brought back a necklace that i wore
earrings uh one of four rings that i had
left so
i kind of brought my own
well scott you were able to actually
take they gave you some of the julie's
gum right
those two packs of gum i threw out were
stolen
oh i see so for inspection reasons right
you got rid of the evidence and y'all
are going to be subpoenaed in a couple
of months cj is referring to the first
on the first s the set of the first
clerks
i had never seen a pickle in a pouch and
it
i was like flapping by the way don't
google pickle in a pouch people
it's not going to be the pouch.com is
now my website
i've never seen it
i just thought it was the craziest
funniest thing and i grabbed it and i do
still have it it's insane it's still in
the pouch because it's in vinegar so
it's 28 years kind of okay yep i still
have it any uh any minor uh minor thefts
trevor from any of the clerks ii or
clerk's three set that you kept or what
or major thefts it doesn't have to be
just minor
wait hey man sorry hey man
i'm not getting him to squeal on
something shut the [ __ ] up boy
the only thing the only thing i remember
stealing was
your heart
god you're so [ __ ] good nailed it
kevin did you walk away with anything
from two
besides obviously the people pestering
you about lord of the rings just my uh
dignity there you go
now i think we took that from you
yeah you were wrong about that actually
i'm sorry no i it was that was uh a
quick day i remember eating at that
where were we shooting it was down in
san pedro it was an actual buena vista
buena vista right near knott's berry
farms oh right but it was an actual
there was a it was a burger king that
was defunct that we took over that was
ready for flattening and once we wrapped
two weeks later they literally flattened
the [ __ ] out of that threatened it but i
remember eating something there like
they had actual uh practical food that
we had we had catering sir we're not
that [ __ ] poor
listen no
scene oh i ordered food in the scene i
don't was i even in the movie honestly i
don't stop it
although funny thing about catering uh
and jeff will back this up the day that
uh
ben affleck showed up i don't know if
you know who ben affleck is um
i think he played a batman once anyway
when
ben affleck came in for that whole
making out with kevin's real life and
he's like that's unhygienic kind of
scene he just strolled up he was like
the first thing to be shot he strolled
up and a bentley literally would still
temporary plates from the dealership and
apparently it was given to him
like that [ __ ] needs more things given
to him um
and so he shot his scene it was like the
first thing we shot we did that scene
and he left
and then later on we shot some more
stuff and then lunch came and then lunch
that day wasn't the regular catering
truck and stuff that we had it was a
sushi truck and like this huge giant
like not the little mini galleons when
you have like oh it's your birthday at
the japanese restaurant that four people
share the little sushi and a boat thing
this thing was like a [ __ ] viking
trawler of [ __ ]
sushi and i was like who's what's with
the sushi was like well ben had said
that he liked sushi i'm like he's
already gone home
thank god because we all had sushi that
day last time i checked affleck wasn't a
clerk right
because literally it was like you know
here's your [ __ ] egg
muffin for our catering but yeah that
was the one thing catering wise we were
like what's this all about i'm like oh
it's this is affleck catering i get it
but thank you for the question about
what we stole
thank you appreciate it buddy
all right nice let's head over here
how are you how are you
huge fan of the original movie uh one
question is whatever happened to olaf
the russian metalhead he's never showed
up in anything else the actor and it
wasn't any other view of skill movies i
think kevin talked about this yeah um
[Music]
at a certain screening
um
kevin because somebody asked about olaf
and
see if i can remember because i'm bad at
retelling
but
he lives in london
and
i don't know what i think somebody had
mentioned also on on social media that
he maybe went to film school after
getting money
for having his face on t-shirts um that
he kind of went back to miramax and said
it's like you never got my okay on that
um so
kevin has since i think gotten over that
because he wasn't too happy about it
right because in in jay and silab
strikes back jay is wearing the
berserker shirt that kevin sells at a
store and he was like yo you had the
rights for my likeness for that movie
you don't have the rights of my likeness
to be selling on t-shirts i got my my i
need my money [ __ ] movie check which
was funny because isn't that the plot of
jay and santa bob strikes back
like oh the irony of it all
uh so the cat got [ __ ] more money
than all [ __ ] four of us on stage
from the original movie got paid to
begin with um and then then he was like
blacklisted
and i guess i didn't know about the
london part that's that's interesting uh
and then they finally settled and so now
kevin does have the rights dust some of
you actually are wearing the berserker
shirt in here uh and stuff like that but
literally that cat is the highest paid
actor from the original clerk's cast
i think like maybe uh tenfold
all right you don't have to throw all
our [ __ ] laundry out there for [ __ ]
sake girl because i remember it's like
there was i think there was a number
that you cut bait cut end the story
trying to have some dignity up here
but yeah uh that's what happened to the
olaf story uh i know i someone said he
tried reaching out to kevin to be part
of three and there we are
you'll see thank you no thank you good
question thanks bud it's probably all
it's probably olaf's cousin like just
curious
is there another future lawsuit in mind
sadly this this will be our last
question we are we're just about out of
time oh what i feel honored here that
i'm the last person to ask you a
question hi everyone i am the vern
and i want to say thank you everyone for
coming out here uh it's been it must be
amazing that
movie that you shot in 94 will become
like a cultural phenomenon
and it's amazing and i thank you all for
being here my main question here is for
brian here sir uh i want to ask you
about what was it late to work with uh
rosario dawson
in towards two did you have to audition
with her
all right um audition or you did yeah
yeah it must be like surreal to like
work with someone like her right next
feature i just wanna get your right well
first of all let me just take a moment
to think about rosario dawson okay
and then let me process the fact that
i've made that
that i've made out in film with now a
jedi
no um
she was brilliant jeff will testify to
this that even our first read through
with her on clerks 2
she totally got the spirit of what
kevin's dialogue was and everything and
you know as us guys when we were hearing
that rosario said yes and uh coming
through this um
after the read i remember kevin asking
her afterwards like what honestly you
know things are cool but what made you
say yes
and in true nature of how
absolutely [ __ ] epically awesome
rosario dawson is she says honestly
i wanted to see how you're going to pull
off this donkey show
[Laughter]
so she was always awesome there were
times where she jay was [ __ ] pranking
her like one of the we talked about
pranks earlier one of the times so
the
uh days in was adjacent to the movies
location in bueno vista so instead of
having trailers on the movie set we all
had rooms at this day's end they just
bought the days in out of rooms because
it was [ __ ] near knott's berry farms
and it was a part of an area where it
was like oh obviously they're renting
rooms by the quarter of an hour flex
stayed in the four seasons yeah exactly
where sushi was served on a woman no
anyway
a woman that's not true
so um that was our room so jay got the
room that was the far end of this
a lot of hotels and or motels especially
in california you walk out of your room
to an outside like literally your car's
right there if you're on the second
floor your railing is right there and
jay had the one on the path that was the
far end and so jay he does this on every
move he does he goes to the target or
walmart or whatever and he has to buy
like a [ __ ] 50 inch tv for the room
because this 23 or 32 inches not big
enough and he wants to buy a stereo
system so he tricks out his room for any
movie set and so that he can do whatever
he wants to play video games whatever so
he would be like yo
yo rosario come over here and she's like
what while we're waiting for setups or
whatever he's like i want you to ask
something and she'd walk down to the
room she'd walk in the room and on the
tv frozen is the scene with her and
colin farrell from alexander
by that reaction i know you know that
scene anyway
he would then hit play and the scene
would go on was like let me ask you
about colin and she'd be like jay come
on man
he caught her three times with that
stupid [ __ ] prank
rosario started me too yeah
she showed up to be honest with you like
j muse now i'm kidding i'm kidding no
but i mean it was that type of fun she
was just really really fun to be around
and i mean trevor will testify to this
as well how just just genuinely epic
like she
she could talk [ __ ] with the best of
them she could talk comics with the best
of them she's an uber nerd but in the
most intellectual
way she's politically on the right side
of history on many topics she's also
just stunningly beautiful and she gets
cast in the most epic situations like
she told me when we were on clerk she's
like i'm trying to get on a star trek
project i'm like [ __ ] you what [ __ ]
jedi why'd you want to be all nothing
first of all i didn't say [ __ ]
in my head i'm saying that because in my
real life i was going oh okay
i did so like but you're a jedi knight
why would you want to cross that that
argument she goes i'm i just i want to
be on that enterprise or something and
stuff so she's a big she's a big star
trek fan so she said i want to see how
the enterprise pulls off the donkey show
[Applause]
she goes up on the holodeck for cards
like engage
all right there you go sir thank you
very much welcome thanks guys thanks
buddy
thank you
hey hey hang on hang on chuck brad
i'm sorry to interrupt the panel but we
we have another special guest coming up
right now ladies and gentlemen let's
hear from movie
hey
everybody it's everybody's favorite
movie
hey everybody
hey by the way i've also been asked to
plug hey there's a clerks 2 group photo
that's still available there are slots
available for the photo uh it's at five
o'clock go to the photo ops area there's
also a clerks group and then there's a
dante and randall duo so please if you
haven't gotten them now you get the
print and everything it's a nice setup
but if you want all of us that you see
on stage that's a five o'clock photo
shoot and there's still openings please
get in there now we're not gonna make
you wait like j muse and we're not gonna
be [ __ ] divas like kevin when it
comes to the camera i'm kidding i'm
kidding
uh but you will get in and out and uh
who knows maybe movie will show up
nice it's great thank you all
thank you kevin
trevor
scott marilyn jeff and brian thank you
all for being here
we are checking brad deuces
thanks
[Music]
for all this
[Music]
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask if anything every saga has a
10-year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith